interview with Venture in his office and
I was scheduled for 45 minutes prep for
24 hours his first two answers took 15
minutes and I literally stopped the
interview and said David I really need
you to go faster this is not working for
me because this is working I have
written questions I have a job too I
have sections we are not getting through
this you know what I mean can we talk
about Fincher for a second because I'm I
mean seven was was pretty formative for
me I think David Fincher movies when
they get released um they should be
national holidays yes yeah I mean he's a
Treasurer and he's and that is he um is
he American or British I don't know I've
never met him oh he's American he's got
he seems like he's got like a British
like Integrity about him I remember when
he did Alien 3 and I was just so such a
dark film such a great uh such a great
uh third film of a franchise I thought
um so I'm obsessed anyway we could talk
I mean listen I have a lot of questions
for you but okay we get dog venture did
you watch mind Hunter yes okay so mine
hunter to me is the is the best thing
Netflix has ever done by a mile I like I
think mindhunter is genius I don't know
if you enjoyed it or I cannot think of a
better thing on Netflix than mine hunter
and I've watched the first season and I
thought it was incredible and uh and
then yeah it made me like you know at
some point I'm gonna have to take on you
know the the psycho killer
um sub-genre as some of my uh some of my
great um
influences have well first of all it's
it's right for I mean there's a million
stories out there
um I the last time I spoke to Fincher
which was for love death and robots I I
said she was cool absolutely I said what
do I need to do to start a GoFundMe for
mind Hunter season three because I will
do it like and I will give you twenty
dollars if you want to make it well I I
I I will Forge ahead and and I I I gotta
watch this next season obviously all 100
it it really is I think it's phenomenal
I can tell we have the same taste yeah
um it's called quality uh entertainment
right um so listen I've I could talk
about Fincher with you the whole time
and other directors and everything but
um I really want to thank you for for
what you do and for making movies
because you have made three great films
that I really
um recommend to everybody
um I have a million things to ask you
about no but um I like throwing a
curveball at the beginning if and I know
a lot of people want to be in business
with you so it might not be tough but if
you could get the financing to make
anything you want uh what would you make
and why wow it's a great question no no
budget you whatever you want and it
could be even any IP what's like the
Dream well see if I told you that would
be
you know that would be giving you the
scoop of the century wouldn't it maybe
what if I get to make this movie someday
right well I have wanted to announce it
and when it was this the glimmer of a
thought how about this I won't make you
I won't put you on the spot but is there
something like a genre or an IP like
something that maybe people don't
associate with you that you're thinking
about you know what I I think the thing
about it is no matter how many IPS I
think of I think about taking on
um I just I feel like I have this
responsibility to myself and to and to
people
to to do my own to tell my own stories
and so I I don't know if there is going
to be an IP that that will do it you
know there was
um
you know their uh Akita is one of my
favorite films and and informative and
there was a world where I thought maybe
I I should take that on or something
like that on and I think in my
conclusion was that you know you know
I've got my own work to put forward and
and uh and Ikea is perfect it's perfect
so you know that that's kind of where I
am sure
um I love that you shot this in IMAX and
you worked with Hoyt and you used IMAX
cameras uh what was when did you realize
you wanted to play in the IMAX Arena it
was it came with the very sort of
foundation of the the film although I
might not have known to say it when I
when I first sort of uttered this this
this thought of making uh and totally
immersive UFO film so I talked to Hoyt
and
um obviously scope was a big thing and I
wanted to push myself and I asked him
what you know how would you capture
actual UFO if you if you had to get
you've had one chance what camera would
you use and that's what we should use in
the movie both in the movie and in the
metal way and he said the IMAX cameras
and um I don't know if he just really
wanted to make an IMAX movie but no uh
you know obviously that that he he has
so much experience in that realm and as
he he what he told me is true there's a
different kind of immersion that happens
with IMAX and there's a different kind
of resolution so for posterity alone
they send these cameras up to space you
know and uh so yeah do you see yourself
using IMAX cameras in your future movies
the way that Nolan does yes yeah look
every story it needs to be told its own
individual way so I I won't be like an
absolutist about how to shoot something
or what to shoot something on but um
once you direct an IMAX there's a
there's a real intoxication that happens
and it it's hard the the possibilities
open up so much when you see that format
and you feel like oh wait a second I can
be somewhere in a real in a more real
sense it's it's pretty addictive I love
talking about the editing process
because that's ultimately where this
whole thing comes together yeah and I
love learning about like first Cuts
versus finished films so did you have a
much longer cut of this yes yeah I mean
yeah my editor is Nick Mansour he's a
guy I worked with
um in with in us
um and uh he's a he's just a a brilliant
guy and a brilliant collaborator the the
first cut you know I don't remember I
feel like it was
three hours and 45 minutes for people
when they hear that that's like an
assembly cut though that's like
literally everything yes which is which
is is fairly typical it may have been
more it felt like a whole lot of movie
and it was and it and it is a whole lot
of movie and um and uh and yeah and so
you know part of my journey sort of
crafting a film is finding the the real
Essentials of a story both from a plot
standpoint but also from the the feeling
and mood of it uh and uh and so he did a
fantastic job what was the last thing
you cut the last scene you cut before
you picture locked and why let me see
let me figure out a creative way to
answer this okay
um
uh let's just say this okay Kiki Palmer
um I've I've uh I've I've never really
worked with her in a real sense I worked
with her briefly on key and peel but
she's a brilliant improviser it turns
out as well as a brilliant um
uh actor and great at memorization and
so let's say you know that first speech
where she comes out and she you know
actor singer dancer and she's given the
safety speech I mean she gave me about
20 different uh reads and takes and
options and it was just one of those
moments where you see somebody
showcasing all the power all the talents
that they've learned to take the written
word but also kind of go off and make it
their own and so you know that's why
I'll say that's one of the hardest
things to choose completely I've heard
that also when they when yeah I've heard
this from other filmmakers like which
take do you actually go with when 10 of
them are fantastic and her dancing it's
like you can just left the camera on
she's just cracking me up with her
dancing so it's very interesting comedy
ends up being one of the more difficult
um things to to edit if not if not the
most difficult because
um every little every frame can uh
Cascade the whole dynamic into a
different direction well the other
problem is and I suppose a lot of
directors have told me that they'll
they'll find a sequence they love they
put they have it there then they're
watching it after two months they're
like well this isn't funny and then they
take it out and only a test screening
that reminds them oh that's still funny
yes there's so many you know with with
with comedy there's so much investment
in trying to figure out what an audience
will
um like and you know often I feel like
if you're having fun then the audience
can feel it
um and if you're not having fun the
audience can feel that you know and
that's kind of on in live when you're in
front of a live audience that's that's
tends to be the truth when you edit it
it's not always true like that when you
edit it sometimes the most boring
thing to shoot ends up being brilliant
for whatever reason it all comes
together and uh that and and vice versa
something that uh was absolutely a blast
on the day and everyone had the whole
crew cracking up can fall flat and uh
that's why every kind of piece needs to
be calibrated